all right who doesn't love a good brunch
and our friends at trattoria reggiano
and downtown salon lynn they know how to
do it right and here to tell us more is
executive chef gino rapa and director of
social media maria bonanno welcome you
guys thank you so much i hear i mean you
guys know how to do italian that's been
very well established but i hear you're
bringing some italiano to our brunch
menu tell us a little bit about what you
guys have going on so we got a couple
different um options here today we have
a cannoli french toast with the cannoli
french toast we griddle on the flat top
we get traditional
cannoli filling fill it up with nice
sicilian cannoli mix there's also
chocolate chips chocolate chips
i mean a cannoli which is already
delicious but now you're put bringing it
to breakfast and you're putting it in my
french toast very decadent this is
fantastic i love this okay how we do it
a little whipped cream on top oh my
goodness
definitely a shareable option for the
brunch table but i wouldn't want to
really
guancaroli crunched up right on top oh
my gosh and this is just the beginning
what else chocolate chips
we also
after you garnish with that with the
powdered sugar we have our italian eggs
benedict italian because of the
prosciutto
and gina will tell you about our mama's
frittata over there okay so
this is the finished product can we take
a look at this gorgeousness here the
cannoli french toast wow that's
incredible okay you said this is the the
eggs benedict here yes and then what
makes this is a difference we use
prosciutto parma instead of like
traditional spinach we also have
rosemary parmesan potatoes which are
outstanding okay and then you have
another you have the bottomless mimosas
i see yes bottomless mimosas bellini's
and bloody mary's with one of the most
affordable prices in the area so
definitely a downtown summerlin favorite
and um is this only on sundays or is it
saturdays saturday and sunday oh we love
that now for people who don't know where
in downtown summerlin where are you guys
located we are right next to the regal
cinemas movie theater across from dave
and buster's there's also bonanno's
pizzeria right next door to us it's so
good if you have not been there it is a
must stop and now we got to go for
brunch let's talk about this final dish
that's over here this looks really
really good what is it this is a
traditional italian in the morning what
we do is a mama's frittata it's called
it's a little bit of sauteed caramelized
onions
crispy potatoes and nice eggs and
prosciutto fried right on top with a
little bit of basil excellent
open-faced omelette is very very
delicious and
right before we went on jillian said
have you ever been there because um
they're famous for their garlic knots
don't forget the garlic nuts definitely
got to check about their new brunch menu
it is time to get your french toast on
i'll be trying that i'm going to send it
over to you jillian i'll save garlic
knot okay
those are my favorite of all